[Music]
all right tonight we can report that the
Trump administration announced 200
foreign nationals have been arrested in
a big roundup of ms-13 gang members
including 64 individuals who illegally
entered as unaccompanied alien children
maybe they would fall under the daca
program by the way only five of the
hundred and ninety eight hundred two
thousand two hundred excuse only five of
the 200 were other than illegal aliens
so this is big news at a big press
conference today we're gonna ask our
next guest about this and the daca
question this is all coming to a head
right now we have eight hundred thousand
undocumented people brought here when
they were young by their parents and
it's one of the biggest issues facing
the lawmakers this fall and there's a
struggle in this entire debate is there
going to be a compromise to give daca
amnesty to 800,000 of these young people
that would include enforcement or is it
just gonna be a blank check amnesty
joining us now Dave brat congressman
from the great Commonwealth of Virginia
he joins us to discuss the latest on
this and this good news first Dave on
the roundup I mean 200 ms-13 violent
gang members they're the most vicious of
the vicious gangs globally let alone
just in the United States that is good
news for the Trump administration and
for this country yep absolutely Laurie I
know you've been working on this for
decades and leading the fight and you
know this it ultimately is about the
rule of law and then economics as well
the left talks about living wage
etcetera and ignores the millions of
folks that are coming in and putting
pressure to lower wages at the same time
they're trying to help the American
worker this was a key election piece of
my campaign you of course played a huge
role in that and president Trump ran on
this on behalf of the American worker
and now with the Republican House and
Senate and White House the first thing
we're discussing right after tax cuts is
doing a democrat bill on daca etcetera
so kind of astounding so I put together
a bill with yeah I know just the the
minimum pieces that conservatives should
demand right
ending chain migration which just
multiplies you know the daka by three to
four times or the dreamer by three to
four times three or four hundred percent
increase and then Eve Arif I which makes
sure that helps both workers know any
new workers are hired legally it helps
employers know they're ok with the law
and then and into this Visa Lottery
which also like you just said just
allows random folks in right no scrutiny
no merit-based not good for the United
States not vetted for national security
and so these are just I put these three
together in one bill then they're not my
work go ahead chairman Goodlatte and
Lamar Smith from Texas have done great
work on all this for decades but I
packaged them together because I think
they represent the will of the American
people
hey David Dave you are leading the
charge on this a few others are and you
named their names we have of course over
in the Senate Tom cotton with the raise
act right also so important but it is
stunning to me that after a year ago
when Donald Trump wins yeah without
compromising on key issues regarding
immigration enforcement
he doesn't compromise he doesn't back
off he doesn't he doesn't say he's gonna
deport all the dreamers either let's
let's be honest about that it didn't do
that I don't think most people are
asking for that but it is astounding
that the GOP obsesses about what to do
with the dreamers when we have all these
other things we need to do I mean right
Obamacare repeal we need to do real real
confirmations of people to staff these
departments who are now that are now
being undermined by Obama appointees I
mean we have a lot to do but for the
Republicans are always obsessed about
doing more for illegal aliens and I know
that sounds harsh to say to it but just
focus on the American people we'll deal
with the you know the illegal aliens but
focus on the American people get the
criminals out of this country and I find
this stunning but you there like giving
away the store before you even get to
the main problem which is enforcement
stop them at the border a quick
turnaround expedited removal and and we
start with oh I'm gonna take care of the
dreamers is what President Trump said
focus on the American work
the American citizen particular the
dreamers I mean that give to taken care
of but you have to rush that so fast in
my view right and I mean as you know and
all your listeners of this is the
central issue right other issues are
hugely important Obamacare taxes we're
gonna get that straight hopefully this
week but this one this is the issue that
separates the swamp from the will of the
American people and this this wasn't
just Trump this was Bernie through Trump
right Bernie it was trending and then
the thing was rigged on the Democrat
side but he was trying to represent the
workers on that side right on a more
progressive you know central planning
big government kind of solution and then
president Trump fortunately won and is
getting us not you know but two tax cuts
the other side of the aisle just so
folks at home know this week the
Democrats raise taxes 10 trillion raise
spending 11 trillion and end up with
more debt and deficit than we do and so
immigration fits into this rights kind
of a bank shot we're not doing well our
welfare system is broke people are
leaving the works they want the
Democrats need an infusion of new voters
Republicans want the cheap labor because
apparently if wages go up for most
Republicans that's a bad thing see I
want wages actually to go up for the
American worker but they want the influx
of the of the low-skilled workers to
keep the wages down this this is drug
I'm telling you my radio listeners of I
think most fox viewers are sick of this
the Republicans never listen to the
American people on immigration they just
refuse to I mean one final question
president Trump's trip to Asia he's
getting trashed by the usual suspects
you know Richard Haass some other
nevertrump her types they didn't get
anything from China but the Chinese
seemed to make a trip up to North Korea
may be working on some type of deal with
that cabbage patch president up there
and North Korea
what do you rate the president's trip
yeah no I he's outstanding he was in the
room today with us on the conference
then came and gave us a pep talk on the
tax cut but he gave us a brief you know
survey of his Asian trip and you know
having tremendous inroads receive
graciously like a king in China he's
he's having talks across the entire
region and all the experts right they
said you know the economy
is gonna go to pot when Trump gets in
the stock market or pom it immediately
the stock market our eyes we're getting
to expect down there never wrong right
the Iran deal
7:3 a deal we kick ready taking it out
on the road for 30 years right and so
he's leading us we've got the respect of
the world again congressman Brad thank
you so much for joining us and I